a toxic algae that's harmful to humans
is spreading from Florida's Gulf Coast
to Atlantic beaches for the first time
in more than a decade the phenomenon
known as red tide can kill fish and
cause respiratory issues in people state
officials say the Gulf Coast bloom now
stretches along 135 miles of Florida
coastline Manuel Bojorquez is in North
Miami Beach where another bloom is
washing ashore Manuel good morning
good morning this is Haulover Beach and
you can see it is empty right now though
it's typically one of the more popular
spots here in South Florida it was shut
down yesterday as officials were trying
to keep people away from the water as
they wait for the slow-moving menace to
pass we don't want anybody out here
today and it be exposed to these toxins
miles of pristine beach along Florida's
Atlantic coast were deserted shut down
after officials confirmed a toxic red
tide bloom just offshore I think mother
nature is getting angry and doing crazy
stuff I can't even really get close to
it without my throat tickle so bad that
I'm constantly red tides are caused by a
naturally occurring toxic algae that is
normally seen on the Gulf Coast
it spread to the Atlantic coast is
believed to be partially caused by
agricultural development around
Florida's wetlands leaving stagnant
pockets of nutrient-rich water that can
then feed the microscopic Menace dr.
Malcolm McFarlane is with Florida
Atlantic University does pollution make
the bloom even worse
so nutrient pollution things like
agricultural runoff and fertilizer
runoff for people's lawns discharge from
septic systems and wastewater treatment
plants those are all things that can act
exacerbate the problem the problem has
plagued coastal communities toxic blooms
devastated Florida's fragile aquatic
ecosystems turning thriving waterways
into death traps for entire schools of
fish and other animals like sea turtles
manatees and dolphins humans and their
pets can become seriously ill from
breathing the poisonous fumes released
when the blooms find their way onto the
beach you feel like you can't breathe
you got something your throat the East
Coast bloom is already impacting
businesses Matt Greenberg's restaurants
at empty as soon as red tide came ashore
the last time I feel like there was this
empty was like during the hurricane when
we came and the whole island was shut
down so
biochemist bill Lauda is an authority on
how chemicals can impact an area's water
supply he recommends steering clear of
the beach until the red tide runs its
course his waters get cooler
hopefully these things will start to go
away just wait and see yeah you know one
of the big questions is how long is this
going to take
the fumes can be so bad out here that
you might be able to make out in that
shot that our crews having to wear masks
out here it is the ninth time since 1957
that red tide has been detected here
along the east coast of Florida the
governor says the state will already
allocate three million dollars in grants
to help affected counties we should
point out that Miami and Palm Beach
County beaches are expected to reopen
today even though red ties still
threatens parts of the coastline
and we'll put on your mask - I'm glad
that the crew is wearing that mask I'm
fascinated by this story and what's
happening because it certainly had heard
about it on the Gulf and now that
Miami's affected as well I hope they can
find a solution to figure it out I hope
so too